(xylophone notes)
- [Narrator] This is Sylvester,
a three-year-old Sulawesi
Tarictic Hornbill.
Endemic to Sulawesi, Indonesia,
its once plentiful population
is now rapidly declining.
Sylvester is on the smaller side,
at about a foot and a half.
Hornbills in general are characterized
by their long, curved bills.
This specific species makes its home
in the tropical lowlands,
swamps and forests
of Sulawesi and nearby islands
where it feeds mainly on fruit,
with the occasional small animal.
(plucked strings music)
But, destruction of these areas
has caused a massive drop in population.
That, along with being hunted
for food and the pet trade,
has left this once common
bird harder to spot.
This is the Sulawesi Tarictic Hornbill.
(xylophone music slows to a stop)
(chime note)